Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. hello welcome to the restless history continuing our epic world cup themed sweep through uh 32 countries of the world that have qualified for the football world cup in qatar uh and today dominic we come to i would guess the country that probably has the least history. The least history. The least history that perhaps people in this country have heard of any country. And that is Costa Rica.
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告广播、抢先收听系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎来到《历史的 rest》，我们将继续我们史诗般的世界杯主题之旅，游历获得卡塔尔男子足球世界杯参赛资格的 32 个国家；多米尼克，今天我们迎来的，我猜可能是历史最少的国家。历史最少。这个国家的人民所知道的历史，可能是所有国家中最少的。这就是哥斯达黎加。
Come on, Tom. You're not a fan of Costa Rican history? I am. This is unbelievable. So Costa Rica is famous for its wildlife, isn't it? It is indeed. It's famous for its red-eyed tree frogs. Right.
得了吧，汤姆。你不是哥斯达黎加历史的粉丝吗？我是。这太令人难以置信了。所以哥斯达黎加因其野生动物而闻名，对吧？确实如此。它因红眼树蛙而闻名。没错。
It's famous for its tremendous program of reforestation. Yeah. It's a great ecotourism destination. It is. And, of course, it's famous for its dinosaurs. Right. Well, I don't know much about Costa Rican dinosaurs. Well, you do.
它以宏大的再造林计划而闻名。是的。这是一个很棒的生态旅游目的地。是的。当然，它也因其恐龙而闻名。对。嗯，我对哥斯达黎加的恐龙了解不多。嗯，你了解的。
You do. It's best known tourist attraction jurassic park on the isla nublar very good very good um but the history i know nothing about it well tom i'll tell you what to make it accessible for you now i know we said from the very beginning of this world cup series that it absolutely wasn't going to be about football but we will start with a tiny bit of football, just a tiny bit, I promise. So the 2014 World Cup, which was held in Brazil, Group D, England were drawn in Group D, and they were drawn along with Italy, Uruguay, and Costa Rica. So a tough group, three former winners, England, Italy, and Uruguay. And lots of people in England said, and said well this will be really hard but at least we'll get three points against the costa ricans
你了解的。它最著名的旅游景点是努布拉岛上的侏罗纪公园。非常好，非常好。嗯，但历史，我对此一无所知。好吧，汤姆，我来告诉你怎么让你能理解它。现在我知道我们在这次世界杯系列的最初就说过，它绝对不会是关于足球的，但我们将从一点点足球开始，就一点点，我保证。所以 2014 年在巴西举办的世界杯，D 组，英格兰被抽到了 D 组，同组的有意大利、乌拉圭和哥斯达黎加。这是一个艰难的小组，有三个前冠军，英格兰、意大利和乌拉圭。英格兰的许多人都说，并且认为这会非常困难，但至少我们在哥斯达黎加人身上能拿到三分。
tom do you know who finished top of that group costa rica they did and you know who finished bottom england england absolutely right now the thing is we should have known better than to underestimate the costa ricans because that was actually their fourth world cup and they have qualified for six and that world cup in 2014 they went on to reach the quarterfinals and they came within a penalty shootout of reaching the semifinals. Extraordinary accomplishment for such a small Central American country. And actually, when you step back from that and you look at it, Costa Rica, as I said, is in Central America and their neighbors. So Nicaragua, Honduras, El Salvador, Guatemala, Panama, none of them have had anything like the same kind of sporting success
汤姆，你知道那个小组头名是谁吗？哥斯达黎加。是的，你知道谁垫底吗？英格兰。英格兰。完全正确。现在的问题是，我们早该知道不该轻视哥斯达黎加人，因为那实际上是他们的第四次世界杯，他们已经六次入围了，而 2014 年那届世界杯，他们一路杀入了四分之一决赛，距离杀入半决赛仅差一场点球大战。对于这样一个中美洲小国来说，这是非凡的成就。事实上，当你退后一步来看待它时，正如我所说，哥斯达黎加位于中美洲，还有它的邻国。尼加拉瓜、洪都拉斯、萨尔瓦多、危地马拉、巴拿马，没有一个取得过哪怕类似程度的体育成功。
that Costa Rica have had. And generally, as you probably know, Tom, in sport as in so much else, it's actually money and stability. Yes. And Costa Rica is a very stable country, isn't it? Exactly. Exactly. So when you look at that list of countries, Nicaragua, Honduras, El Salvador, Guatemala, many of those countries are some of the most violent countries in the world, higher homicide rates, higher imprisonment rates than anywhere else. They're historically very unstable, and they're also extremely poor. But if you look at any ranking in Latin America, Costa Rica is not merely the safest country in Central America. So
正如哥斯达黎加所取得的那样。而且总的来说，正如你可能知道的，汤姆，在体育运动中和在其他很多事情一样，实际上是金钱和稳定。是的。哥斯达黎加是一个非常稳定的国家，对吧？没错。没错。所以当你看看那份国家名单：尼加拉瓜、洪都拉斯、萨尔瓦多、危地马拉，其中许多国家是世界上最暴力的国家之一，凶杀率、监禁率比其他任何地方都高。它们历史上非常不稳定，而且也极其贫困。但是，如果你看看拉丁美洲的任何排名，哥斯达黎加不仅是中美洲最安全的国家。所以
as you said, an extremely popular ecotourism destination where you can be pretty confident that you won't get into any trouble. But it's one of the most affluent countries in Latin America. So it's comparable only really with Uruguay, Chile, and Argentina. So the country's right in the South. Now, when you look at it superficially, there's no obvious reason why that should be the case. Because in Costa Rica, they have the same Spanish language, they have the same customs, they have the same kind of ethnicity as people do in Nicaragua and Honduras and so on. So what is the explanation? Why is Costa Rica such an outlier? And to answer that, Tom, do you know where we need to go back to? No, I literally know nothing about the history of Costa Rica. I cannot put into words how little I know about the history of Costa Rica because I know nothing, nothing, literally nothing.
正如你所说，这是一个极其受欢迎的生态旅游目的地，你可以非常确信自己不会惹上任何麻烦。但它是拉丁美洲最富裕的国家之一。所以它真正能与之相比的只有乌拉圭、智利和阿根廷。所以这个国家位于南方。现在，当你表面上看它时，没有明显的理由说明为什么会这样。因为在哥斯达黎加，他们说着同样的西班牙语，有着同样的习俗，有着与尼加拉瓜、洪都拉斯等地的人们相同的种族。那么解释是什么？为什么哥斯达黎加会是一个如此奇特的特例？为了回答这个问题，汤姆，你知道我们需要回到哪里吗？不，我真的对哥斯达黎加的历史一无所知。我无法用语言来形容我对哥斯达黎加的历史了解得多么少，因为我一无所知，一无所知，真的什么都不知道。
I'll be frank with you. You're going to to be educated you don't even need to educate yourself because I will do it thank you uh we are going back to the Costa Rican civil war of the 1940s very exciting talk wow okay okay who knew that they'd had a civil war I suppose Costa Ricans do but not many people distracted by the stuff that was going on in the 1940s I suppose and their eyes were not on Costa Rica where the main action was happening. So, okay, let's pull the camera right back. If you're in Costa Rica in the 1940s, where are you? So the bottom end of Central America,
我跟你直说吧。你要被科普了，你甚至不需要自我科普，因为我会代劳。谢谢。我们要回到 20世纪 40年代的哥斯达黎加内战。非常令人兴奋的话题，哇，好吧，好吧。谁知道他们有过内战？我想哥斯达黎加人知道，但没多少人知道。他们被 20世纪 40年代发生的其他事情分散了注意力，我想，他们的目光没有注视主战场所在的哥斯达黎加。所以，好吧，让我们把镜头拉远。如果你身处 20世纪 40年代的哥斯达黎加，你在哪里？中美洲的南端，
you've got Nicaragua to the north, you've got Panama to the south. And historically, this has been the backwater of backwaters. So before the Spanish came to theicas um there were obviously people in costa rica pre-columbian people but there weren't you know great empires and cities as there were in what are now mexico and peru the spanish called it the costa rica they're kind of the rich coast basically um from hope rather than anything else they hoped there would be gold there so like greenland the vice is calling it green exactly right marketing scam they hope there's gold
北边是尼加拉瓜，南边是巴拿马。历史上，这里一直是偏远之地的偏远之地。所以在西班牙人来到美洲之前，哥斯达黎加显然有人居住，也就是前哥伦布时期的人民，但这里并没有像现在的墨西哥和秘鲁那样伟大的帝国和城市。西班牙人称它为“哥斯达黎加”，基本上可以说是“富饶海岸”的意思，与其说是事实，不如说是出于某种美好的愿望。他们希望那里有黄金，所以就像格陵兰岛一样，维京人称之为绿色。完全正确，这是一场营销骗局。他们希望那里有黄金，
and there's a tiny bit of gold but there's not very much and it takes them ages to conquer it they basically don't conquer it for about 50 years almost all the indigenous people are wiped out through disease and after that basically i mean to be to cut a very long story short nothing ever really happens in costa rica it's very underpopulated there's no native labor so there's disease. And after that, basically, I mean, to cut a very long story short, nothing ever really happens in Costa Rica. It's very underpopulated. There's no native labor. So there's no point establishing a big kind of hacienda, the big kind of estates that people establish in much of Latin America. It's very poor. It's very sparsely populated. It's kind of peasants. Even the governor, the Spanish colonial governor, has to basically farm his own crops and even kind of look after his own garden because there aren't enough domestic
并且确实有一点点黄金，但没有多少，而且他们花了好久才征服它。他们花了大约 50年才基本上将其征服，几乎所有的土著居民都因疾病而灭亡。在那之后，基本上，我是说，长话短说，哥斯达黎加从来没有真正发生过什么大事。这里人口非常稀少，没有本土劳动力，所以有疾病。在那之后，基本上，我是说，长话短说，哥斯达黎加从来没有真正发生过什么大事。这里人口非常稀少，没有本土劳动力。所以没有必要建立大型的庄园，那种人们在拉丁美洲大部分地区建立的大庄园。这里非常贫穷。人口非常稀少。基本上都是农民。甚至连总督，也就是西班牙殖民地总督，基本上也得自己种庄稼，甚至还得照顾自己的菜园，因为没有足够的家养
servants and laborers and things to do it for him and as you no doubt know at the end of the napoleonic wars much of what's new new spain breaks away from madrid and so costa rica becomes independent kind of despite itself and it goes from one entity to another. It's part of the Mexican empire. It's part of what's called the Federal Republic of Central America. At one point, some American adventurers even tried to take it over and fail, but it ends up as this kind of independent republic. And in the 19th century, the big thing that happens is coffee. So in the 1820s, the coffee trade really takes off. And actually the biggest customer is Britain. So they start an Anglo-Costa Rican bank for coffee growers.
仆人和劳动力来帮他做这些事。正如你无疑知道的那样，拿破仑战争结束后，新西班牙的大部分地区脱离了马德里独立，因此哥斯达黎加有点身不由己地独立了，它从一个实体转变为另一个实体。它是墨西哥帝国的一部分。它是所谓中美洲联邦共和国的一部分。有一段时间，一些美国冒险家甚至试图接管它但失败了，但它最终成为了这样一个独立的共和国。在 19世纪，发生的大事件是咖啡。所以在 19世纪 20年代，咖啡贸易真正腾飞了。实际上最大的客户是英国。因此，他们为咖啡种植者成立了一家英属哥斯达黎加银行。
They build a railway from the coffee estate to the coast. And this, presumably, is when the deforestation happens. Yeah, exactly. They're now busy repairing. Yes, absolutely. But even so, Costa Rica is still very underpopulated. No big cities, no big estates. There's not much to fight over.
他们修建了一条从咖啡庄园到海岸的铁路。这大概就是砍伐森林发生的时候吧。是的，exactly。他们现在正忙着修复。是的，绝对是。即便如此，哥斯达黎加仍然人口稀少。没有大城市，没有大庄园。没有什么好争夺的。
And so although there's a bit of turbulence in its politics, there's nothing like as turbulent as in Latin American countries where there's a lot of tension between big mercantile cities and kind of agricultural magnates between liberals and conservatives, Blancos and Colorados, all that stuff that you get in the 19th century. The other thing about Costa Rica in the 19th century, before we get back to 1940, we often completely forget this in English speaking.
因此，尽管其政治有点动荡，但远不像拉丁美洲其他国家那样动荡，在那些国家，大型商业城市与农业巨头之间、自由派与保守派之间、布兰科派与科洛拉多派之间存在着很多紧张关系，所有这些在 19世纪都会发生的事情。关于 19世纪的哥斯达黎加，在我们回到 1940年之前，还有一件事，我们在英语世界里经常完全忘记这一点。
Latin America was often very progressive. So they abolished the death penalty in 1871. They had freedom of religion. They had separation of church and state and the separation of kind of the judiciary and the legislature and the executive. So they're quite forward thinking. And their politics is not
拉丁美洲往往非常进步。因此，他们在 1871年废除了死刑。他们拥有宗教自由。他们实现了政教分离，以及司法权、立法权和行政权的分离。所以他们相当具有前瞻性。而且他们的政治不是
ideological it's all about patrons and bosses big bosses which makes it very confusing so that's all the sort of context now 1940 so the president at the turn of the 1940s is a bloke called rafael angel calderon and he is a doctor he's been educated um interesting in belgium so almost everybody in this story that we're going to meet has kind of european links somewhere or other and he had come into he'd become president as the sort of the the friend of the of the of the coffee oligarchs as they're known so the people who control the coffee is that just a coffee oligarch yeah you could be a good thing to be yeah there's a lot of money in coffee um but over time, like a lot of Latin American politicians in the same period, he becomes more and more populist.
意识形态的，它完全关乎庇护人和老板、大老板，这让人非常困惑。所以这些都是背景。现在到了 1940年： 1940年代初的总统是一个叫拉斐尔·安赫尔·卡尔德隆（Rafael Ángel Calderon）的家伙，他是一名医生，他在比利时接受过教育，嗯，有趣的是，在这个故事中我们将遇到的几乎所有人，在某处都有着欧洲联系。他成为总统是作为所谓的“咖啡寡头”的朋友，因为咖啡寡头就是这样被称为的，也就是控制咖啡的人。这只是一个咖啡寡头吗？是的，成为这个会是一件好事。咖啡里有很多钱。但随着时间的推移，就像同一时期的许多拉丁美洲政治家一样，他变得越来越民粹主义。
And he sort of carries that welfare policies. But he doesn't start wearing epaulettes or caps or anything. He doesn't. He doesn't quite go that far. Now, in Costa Rica, there's a constitutional provision that you can't run for consecutive terms as president. So Mr. Calderon, Señor Calderon, can't run for consecutive terms as president so mr calderon senor calderon can't run again and he gets basically a sort of dog's body of his so this is kind of putin behavior
他开始推行福利政策。但他没有开始穿肩章制服或戴军帽什么的。他没有。他还没有走到那一步。现在，在哥斯达黎加，有一项宪法规定，你不能连续担任总统。所以卡尔德隆先生，卡尔德隆先生，不能连续担任总统。所以卡尔德隆先生，卡尔德隆先生不能再次参选，他基本上找了一个唯命是从的走狗。所以这有点像普京的行为。
yeah he's in a medford he has a dog's body of his called teodoro picardo mickalski to succeed him mickalski mr yes mr picardo mickalski his mother is from Krakow in Poland. Right. And he, very impressively, Tom, he speaks English, Polish, and French, as well as some Russian, Italian, and German. I mean, who knew that Costa Rican politicians were such polyglots? Does he speak any American? Any Spanish?
是的，他有一个唯命是从的走狗，名叫特奥多罗·皮卡多·米卡尔斯基（Teodoro Picardo Michalski），来接替他。米卡尔斯基先生？是的，皮卡多·米卡尔斯基先生，他的母亲来自波兰克拉科夫。对。而且，汤姆，他非常令人印象深刻，他会说英语、波兰语和法语，还会说一些俄语、意大利语和德语。我的意思是，谁知道哥斯达黎加政治家竟然是这样的多语通？他说任何美洲语言吗？任何西班牙语吗？
No, any American languages, kind of. What, Native American languages? Yes. Kind of like Nahuatl or something. Yes. No. No. any spanish any spanish no any american languages kind of uh what native american languages yes kind of like narwhal yes no no no one speaks that in costa rica so it'd be pointless for us right okay unless he was like a sort of jr tolkien figure learning it in his attic yes anyway he doesn't but you know what he is he's a historian is he i'm on his side well are you though because i don't know like like a lot of historians he's a bit of a weed he's a sort of plastic weak figure mr picardo mickalski now as as we get further into the 1940s uh costa rica starts to become a little bit unstable because basically the the populist policies that senor calderon the doctor was was um promoting and then
不，任何美洲语言，有点像。什么，美洲印第安语言？是的。有点像纳瓦特尔语什么的。是的。不。不。任何西班牙语？任何西班牙语？不。任何美洲语言，有点像，什么，美洲印第安语言？是的，有点像纳瓦特尔语？是的，不，不，在哥斯达黎加没有人说这个，所以对我们来说毫无用处。好吧，除非他像某种 J·R·托尔金式的人物，在阁楼里学习它。是的，无论如何，他没有，但你知道他是什么吗？他是个历史学家。是吗？我站在他这一边。真的吗，因为我不知道，就像很多历史学家一样，他有点像个懦夫。他是一个毫无生气的软弱人物，皮卡多·米卡尔斯基先生。现在，随着我们进一步深入 20世纪 40年代，哥斯达黎加开始变得有点不稳定，因为基本上，那位医生卡尔德隆先生一直在推行、然后
his his sort of flunky picardo is is they provoke great unrest among the kind of professional classes and the coffee people and so on and as is so often the way in latin america they become increasingly kind of authoritarian to kind of defend those policies and they basically rely start to rely more and more on militias provided by the Communist Party. So you've got this kind of growing tension, sort of violence on the streets and so on. And the stakes are getting higher and higher. And of course, the Cold War is in full swing by the late 1940s. So there's just a sense, you know, the temperature is rising. In 1947, there is a general strike called the Huelga de Brazos Caídos, the Strike of Fallen Arms.
他的走狗皮卡多也在推行的民粹主义政策，在专业阶层和咖啡阶层等群体中引发了巨大的骚乱。正如拉丁美洲经常发生的那样，为了捍卫这些政策，他们变得越来越独裁，并基本上开始越来越依赖由共产党提供的民兵。所以你有了这种不断增长的紧张局势，街头暴力等等。而且赌注越来越高。当然，到 20世纪 40年代末，冷战已经全面展开。所以就是有一种感觉，你知道，气温在上升。1947年，发生了一场总罢工，被称为“垂臂罢工”（Huelga de Brazos Caídos）。
I don't know why it's called that, but anyway, there's a general strike, and the government is very cross about this and starts intimidating merchants and manufacturers and so on. So there's a real sense of pressure. And what really adds to this is that I said there were term limits. It's preventing consecutive terms. But Calderon, like Vladimir Putin, I suppose. Can now come back. It can come back in the next election in 1948. And what's the weedy historian making of this?
我不知道为什么叫这个名字，但无论如何，发生了一场总罢工，政府对此非常生气，并开始恐吓商人和制造商等等。所以有一种真正的压力感。真正加剧这一点的是，我刚才说过有任期限制。它禁止连任。但卡尔德隆，就像弗拉基米尔·普京一样，我想。现在可以在 1948年的下次选举中卷土重来。而那个毫无生气的历史学家对此有何看法？
He's just going to step aside in a weedy historian fashion, I suppose. I know you're disappointed by this, Tom. I am disappointed. Would you do this? Maybe you would. No, I wouldn't. I would learn the lesson of history and strike, and I'd strike hard. Okay, well, he didn't.
他打算以一种唯命是从的历史学家的姿态退下来，我想。我知道你对此感到失望，汤姆。我很失望。你会这样做吗？也许你会。不，我不会。我会吸取历史的教训并进行反击，而且我会狠狠地反击。好吧，嗯，他没有。
Because that, Dominic, that's what history teaches. It does. I've told you many times, the lesson of history is eat your neighbors before they eat you. That's the lesson of history. Anyway, listen, Calderon is going to run again, and everybody knows this, and everybody knows he's desperate to win. And his opponents, who are the sort of conservative middle classes and so on, and people who are worried that he's too authoritarian, they put up as their candidate a newspaperman called Otilio Ulate Blanco. And everyone knows it's going to be very close and contentious. And in the lead up to
因为汤姆，历史教导的就是这个。确实如此。我跟你说过很多次了，历史的教训就是：吃掉你的邻居，免得被他们吃掉。这就是历史的教训。不管怎样，听着，卡尔德隆要再次参选，每个人都知道这一点，每个人都知道他渴望获胜。他的反对者，也就是所谓的保守派中产阶级等等，以及担心他过于独裁的人，推举了一位名叫奥蒂利奥·乌拉特·布兰科（Otilio Ulate Blanco）的新闻工作者作为他们的候选人。每个人都知道竞争将非常激烈且充满争议。在
election day, on the 8th of February, 1948 1948 there are all kinds of dark rumors that there's going to be fraud and there's going to be ballot stuffing and all this the the result is announced and the newspaper bloke pilate blanco has won 55 of the vote and calderon has won 45 so the big man the populist who everyone thought was going to be the quasi dictator has actually lost like tom alex salmon in the scotia independence referendum that wasn't the analogy that i was going to look for because he takes he you know he takes the stage and he says this is the mainstream media fake news well very examined i haven't lost at all there's been all kinds of fraud in this election i warned about it beforehand and i'm not going to accept the results.
2月 8日选举日（1948年）临近之际，有各种各样的黑暗传言，说会有舞弊，会有塞选票等等，结果公布了，那个报人乌拉特·布兰科赢得了 55%的选票，而卡尔德隆赢得了 45%。所以那个大人物，那个被所有人认为会成为准独裁者的民粹主义者，实际上输了。就像汤姆，亚历克斯·萨尔蒙德在苏格兰独立公投中一样。那不是我本来要找的比喻，因为他登台说这是主流媒体的假新闻。好吧，非常像萨尔蒙德，我根本没有输，这次选举中存在各种舞弊，我事先就警告过，我不会接受结果。
And mysteriously, the day after the election, a suspicious fire destroys a lot of the ballots. So quite Trump. Quite Trump. Tom, finally. Yes, that's what I've been. I've probably been very hard on Calderon here, but I thought, you know, why not? So a fire destroys a lot of the ballots uh so congress which is controlled by calderon supporters cancels the elections three
而且神秘的是，选举后的第二天，一场可疑的大火烧毁了大量的选票。所以很像特朗普。很像特朗普。汤姆，终于。是的，这就是我一直以来想说的。我在这里对卡尔德隆可能有点严厉，但我想，嗯，为什么不呢？因此，一场大火烧毁了许多选票，
weeks later throws them out and picardo the weedy historian says he'll carry on as president for the time being until they that's not what to do that. No, he's doing what he's told. He's doing what he's told by Calderon. So there's absolute outrage at this, Tom. Complete outrage. And Olate, the newspaperman, is outraged. He says, I've had the election stolen from me. He's going around.
由卡尔德隆支持者控制的国会在三周后取消了选举，将其作废，那个软弱的历史学家皮卡多说他将暂时继续担任总统，直到他们……这不是该做的事。不，他正在做被告知要做的事。他正在做卡尔德隆吩咐他做的事。所以对此绝对是群情激愤，汤姆。完全群情激愤。报人乌拉特感到愤怒。他说，我的选举被偷走了。他四处奔走。
He goes to his friend. What's the point of being a newspaperman if you can't? Well, his newspaper is obviously denouncing this. Yes, of course. I mean mean you know fake news well i think the costa rican civil war is definitive proof that people who think their mainstream media control politics are wrong it's all right okay anyway this newspaper bloke he goes to his friend dr valverde i don't know anything about him so i can't provide any any
他去找他的朋友。如果不能这样做，当报人有什么意义？嗯，他的报纸显然在谴责这一点。是的，当然。我的意思是，你知道假新闻。嗯，我认为哥斯达黎加内战是绝对的证据，证明那些认为主流媒体控制政治的人是错的。好吧，好吧。不管怎样，这个报人去找他的朋友瓦尔韦德医生（Dr. Valverde），我对这个人一无所以，所以我无法提供任何
form of pen portrait let your imaginations do the work with dr i imagine him he has a little pencil mustache and faintly sinister kind of nazi glasses and he does experiments on amphibians for fun but ultimately i think a kindly man tom no no he's the embodiment of evil no no that's not why i'm at dr is he goody you've got the sides completely muddled up oh i know nothing about this i'm just going you're out of your depth tom you don't know who the good guys are in this story at all. Dr. Valverde is very kind
人物素描，让你们的想象力伴随着瓦尔韦德医生自由发挥吧。我脑海中的他留着一撮小胡子，戴着隐隐透着阴险的纳粹式眼镜，他为了好玩而在两栖动物身上做实验，但最终我认为他是个善良的人，汤姆。不，不，他是邪恶的化身。不，不，这不是我的意思。瓦尔韦德医生是好人吗？你把阵营完全搞混了。哦，我对这个一无所知。我只是在说……汤姆，你根本不在状态，你根本不知道这个故事里谁是好人。瓦尔韦德医生对
to children, gives sweets to the homeless. Okay. He's a great man. He's a great man.
孩子们非常好，给无家可归者送糖果。好吧。他是个伟大的人。他是个伟大的人。
But this is a dark day for Dr. Valverde because Dr. Valverde, Tom, is hosting... Do you remember who Atelier Olate Blanco was? Yes, he's the newspaper man.
但对瓦尔韦德医生来说，这是黑暗的一天，因为瓦尔韦德医生，汤姆，正在接待……你还记得奥蒂利奥·乌拉特·布兰科是谁吗？是的，他是那个报人。
Yeah, he's hosting him at a meeting. He's been robbed. He's been robbed. Yeah, he's been robbed of the election. Atelier Olate Blanco has gone to meet Dr. Valverde. Right. But what's the significance of that? Well, the police surround Dr. Valverde's house, Tom.
对，他在一次会议上接待了他。他被抢劫了。他被抢劫了。是的，他的选举胜利被剥夺了。奥蒂利奥·乌拉特·布兰科去见瓦尔韦德医生。对。但这有什么意义呢？嗯，警察包围了瓦尔韦德医生的房子，汤姆。
Because they know he's evil. Shots ring out and Dr. Valverde is shot in his own doorway. And Olate Blanco escapes, but is later captured. Maybe it was for the best. No, not for the best. So this is a sign that the Calderonistas are determined to do anything in their power to retain control of Costa Rica, Tom. Right. But they have reckoned, do you know who they've reckoned without?
因为他们知道他是邪恶的。枪声响起，瓦尔韦德医生在自家的门廊被枪杀。乌拉特·布兰科逃脱了，但随后被捕。也许这是最好的结果。不，不是最好的结果。所以这表明卡尔德隆派决心不惜一切代价夺回对哥斯达黎加的控制权，汤姆。对。但他们算漏了，你知道他们算漏了谁吗？
A figure we've not yet mentioned, but the greatest figure in Costa Rica's history. John Hammond. What? John Hammond? Is that your suggestion? John Hammond? Who's John Hammond? He that your suggestion? John Hammond?
一个我们尚未提及的人物，但却是哥斯达黎加历史上最伟大的人物：约翰·哈蒙德（John Hammond）。什么？约翰·哈蒙德？这是你的建议吗？约翰·哈蒙德？约翰·哈蒙德是谁？
Who's John Hammond? He sets up Jurassic Park. No, it's not him. They have reckoned without Don Pepe himself. Jose Figueres Ferrer, named Tom to conjure with. To echo down the ages. In the world of Costa Rican,
约翰·哈蒙德是谁？他建立了侏罗纪公园。不，不是他。他们算漏了堂佩佩（Don Pepe）本人。何塞·菲格雷斯·费雷尔（Jose Figueres Ferrer），一个让人浮想联翩的名字。一个在岁月中回响的名字。在哥斯达黎加的历史学界里。
Costa Rican, historiography. So tell me about him. Do we know about him? I think he is such a big figure And he is the father Of modern Costa Rica We should absolutely
所以跟我讲讲他。我们了解他吗？我认为他是一个如此重要的人物，而且他是现代哥斯达黎加之父。我们绝对应该
Take a break To compose ourselves And come back after the break To talk about Don Pepe Okay I'm Marina Hyde And I'm Richard Osman And together we host
休息一下，调整一下状态，休息回来后再来谈论堂佩佩。好的。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持
The Rest Is Entertainment It's your weekly fix Of entertainment news Reviews Splash of showbiz gossip And on our Q&A We pull back the curtain On entertainment And we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
《娱乐的 rest》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦消息的地方，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. hello welcome back to the rest of history where we are talking about the costa rican civil war a subject i know literally nothing about um but dominic you know lots about it and you are building up to um perhaps the most exciting moment in this already i have say, thrill-filled episode. And you're introducing Mr. Big, Senor Grande, Don Pepe. Don Pepe, Jose Figueres, the big man of Costa Rican history, Tom. So I told you before the break,
如果你想要无广告广播、独家加更节目以及抢先购买现场演出门票的机会，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。大家好，欢迎回到《历史的 rest》，我们正在讨论哥斯达黎加内战，一个我literally一无所知的题材，嗯，但是多米尼克，你对它了解很多，你正在为……嗯，可能是这个本就充满了惊险刺激的单集里最激动人心的时刻做铺垫。你正在介绍大人物，西诺尔·格兰德（Senor Grande），堂佩佩。堂佩佩，何塞·菲格雷斯，哥斯达黎加历史上的大人物，汤姆。所以我刚才在休息前告诉过你，
if you were listening, as I hope you were, that all the people in this story had European connections. This is Sergio Don Pepe. His parents were from Barcelona. And he'd been born in Costa Rica in 1906, just after they immigrated to Costa Rica. And his Catalan identity was always very important to him. He's very independent-minded, is Figueres.
如果你在听的话，正如我希望的那样，这个故事里的所有人都有欧洲背景。这就是瑟吉欧·堂佩佩。他的父母来自巴塞罗那。他于 1906年出生在哥斯达黎加，就在他们移民到哥斯达黎加之后不久。他的加泰罗尼亚身份对他来说始终非常重要。菲格雷斯非常有独立精神。
Like the Catalans tend to be. Yes, exactly. Well, that's why he sort of says, I'm Catalan. I'm always very Catalan. I'm very strong-willed. He's sent to a seminary. He doesn't like it at all. He drops out in the 1920s, and he goes off to Boston to study at MIT,
就像加泰罗尼亚人往往表现出的那样。是的，完全如此。这就是为什么他有点像是在说，我是加泰罗尼亚人。我总是非常加泰罗尼亚。我意志非常坚强。他被送进了一所神学院。他一点也不喜欢。他在 20世纪 20年代退学了，然后前往波士顿在麻省理工学院学习，
the Massachusetts Institute of Technology. But he's studying hydroelectric science at MIT, and he finds it, unsurprisingly, I think it's fair to say, very boring. So he drops out of that as well, and he puts himself through a curriculum he's devised himself of reading at the Boston Public Library. And he reads Cervantes, he reads Kant, he reads Nietzsche, and he reads H.G. Wells. So he's a clever man. He comes back to Costa Rica. He becomes a big coffee
也就是马萨诸塞理工学院（MIT）。但他当时在麻省理工学院学习水力科学，不出所料，我认为公平地说，他觉得非常无聊。所以他也从那里退学了，然后通过自己在波士顿公共图书馆制定的阅读课程进行自我教育。他阅读塞万提斯、康德、尼采和 H.G.威尔斯。所以他是个聪明人。他回到了哥斯达黎加。他成了一个大咖啡
grower and it would delight you to hear, Tom, he is a manufacturer of rope, which I know from your reading of Patrick O'Brien you're very interested in. Okay, I'm against him. He is a philanthropist. He's a very kindly kind of Victorian paternalist employer. He builds houses
种植者，听到这个你一定会很高兴，汤姆，他是一家绳索制造商，根据你对帕特里克·奥布莱恩（Patrick O'Brian）作品的阅读，我知道你对此非常感兴趣。好吧，我反对他。他是一位慈善家。他是一位非常慈祥的、维多利亚式的大家长式雇主。他为工人建造房屋。
for his workers. Maybe I'm not against him then. Yeah, exactly harsh on dr valverde yes i was now dead and you cannot afford to be harsh on don pepe okay i'm all for don pepe he establishes a nice vegetable farm for his workers fifa don pepe a dairy with free milk so what's not to like he's a a great fellow. Anyway, he's a kindly man, I think it's fair to say to his sort of workers. But in the early 1940s, he had become increasingly alarmed by the authoritarian direction of the Calderon administration. And he had in fact been exiled for two years in Mexico because he'd said, this sort of authoritarian president is going
也许我又不反对他了？是的，完全正确。之前对瓦尔韦德医生的评价太严厉了。是的，我当时是这么觉得。现在他死了，你不能对堂佩佩太严厉。好吧，我完全支持堂佩佩。他为工人们建立了一个漂亮的蔬菜农场，菲格雷斯，堂佩佩，一个提供免费牛奶的奶牛场。所以有什么不喜欢他的呢？他是个了不起的家伙。不管怎样，他是个善良的人，我认为对他的工人们来说公平地说。但在 20世纪 40年代初，他变得越来越对卡尔德隆政府的独裁方向感到惊慌。事实上，他曾在墨西哥流亡了两年，因为他说，这种独裁总统最终会
to end up as a communist and you should watch out. He comes home and in the run-up to that election, he had become a major figure in something called the Caribbean Legion. And the Caribbean Legion is a kind of pro-democracy group across the Caribbean. They are very opposed to the dictator Somoza in Nicaragua and Rafael Trujillo, the horrible dictator in the Dominican Republic. And one of their members, Tom, who you'll definitely have heard of, and we won't need to provide an invented pen portrait of, is a young man called Fidel Castro. He's a member of the Caribbean Legion. So the Caribbean Legion think, basically, if we can have Costaica as a democratic base in
变成一个共产主义者，你们应该小心。他回国了，在那次大选的前夕，他成为了加勒比军团（Caribbean Legion）的重要人物。加勒比军团是加勒比地区的一个亲民主组织。他们非常反对尼加拉瓜的独裁者索摩查（Soma）和多米尼加共和国可怕的独裁者拉斐尔·特鲁希略（Rafael Trujillo）。而他们的成员之一，汤姆，你绝对听说过，我们不需要为他提供虚构的人物素描，就是一个叫菲德尔·卡斯特罗（Fidel Castro）的年轻人。他是加勒比军团的成员。所以加勒比军团基本上认为，如果我们能把哥斯达黎加作为中美洲的民主基地，
central america then we can spread democracy to the rest of central america and figueres don pepe is very keen on this and when he hears about the murder of dr valverde not as you claim an experimenter on frock but a but a lover a kindly gentleman i it's fair, more accurate to say, a man of whom we know absolutely, you and I know absolutely nothing. But maybe, Dominic, maybe we have some, who knows, perhaps some Costa Rican listeners. And if we do, or we have anybody who knows anything about Costa Rican history, they could tell us.
那么我们就能将民主传播到中美洲的其他地方，而菲格雷斯，堂佩佩对此非常热心。当他听到瓦尔韦德医生被谋杀的消息时——正如你所说，不是一个青蛙实验者，而是一个恋人，一个慈祥的绅士——我觉得更准确地说是一个我们绝对一无所知的人，你和我绝对一无所知的人。但是也许，多米尼克，也许我们有一些，谁知道呢，也许有一些哥斯达黎加听众。如果我们有，或者我们有任何人了解哥斯达黎加历史，他们可以告诉我们。
Yeah. I can assure you, I have scoured what few books there are on Costa Rican history, and I can find nothing about dr well anyway listen figueres decides this is my chance basically figueres is don pepe just just to be it's don pepe yes i'll call him figueres from that throughout let's put down pepper because he sounds too much like a pizza or something he sounds like a brand of sherry doesn't he he does he's actually not a pizza at all that would be italian he's a he's a brand of sherry he's not he's not he's figueres he's a very impressive person. Figueres says, right, this is it. We're going to have to trigger an uprising. The election has been stolen and all this stuff. And he's raised this little army. of anti-communists, of people who represent the coffee interests, but also people on the left who are, you know, they're left-wing, but they're pro-democracy and they're suspicious of the kind of
是的。我向你保证，我已经搜遍了哥斯达黎加历史仅存的几本书，关于瓦尔韦德医生我什么也没找到……无论如何，听着，菲格雷斯认为这就是我的机会，基本上，菲格雷斯就是堂佩佩，只是为了……是堂佩佩，是的。我通篇都叫他菲格雷斯。让我们叫他堂佩佩，因为他听起来太像披萨什么的了。他听起来像个雪利酒品牌，不是吗？他确实是的。他其实根本不是披萨，那是意大利的。他是一个雪利酒品牌，他不是，他不是，他是菲格雷斯，他是一个非常令人印象深刻的人。菲格雷斯说，好吧，就是这样。我们必须引发一场起义。选举被偷了，诸如此类的事情。他组建了这支由反共人士、代表咖啡利益的人士，以及也是左翼但支持民主、对卡尔德隆政权的独裁保持警惕的左翼人士组成的小部队。
authoritarianism of the Calderon regime. So this little National Liberation Army fights its way into the second city within a couple of weeks. So the fighting sort of breaks out in march 1948 and by the 20 12th of april they're in carthago which is the second largest city they're kind of carrying more before carthage yeah named after carthage and so this is really becoming quite a theme of our carthaginian theme cup episodes isn't it we've had we've had uh ganabal and now so maybe when the world cup is over, we can repackage this series, Tom, as a...
所以这支小型国民解放军在几周内一路战斗进入了第二大城市。因此，战斗在 1948年 3月爆发，到 4月 20日（原文如此），他们已经到达了卡塔哥（Carthago），这是第二大城市，他们一路势如破竹……迦太基，因迦太基而得名。所以这真的成了一个贯穿我们迦太基主题世界杯节目的主题了，不是吗？我们有了汉尼拔，现在又有……所以也许当世界杯结束后，我们可以把这个系列重新包装，汤姆，作为一个……
Yes. The world history... Carthage around the world, yeah. Yeah, exactly. So basically, the support for the government is melting away, and they're increasingly reliant on the communists, on this communist militias. So the capital is San Jose,
是的。世界历史……“迦太基环游世界”，对。是的，完全如此。所以基本上，政府的支持正在瓦解，他们越来越依赖共产党人，依赖这些共产党民兵。因此，首都圣何塞，
and the communists are going to hold up in the capital. And the question is, are they going to hold out while Figueres' little army are approaching? Or are they going to accept defeat? And it's at this point that the United States is really crucial, because, of course, this is the Cold War. The Americans are very, very anti-communist. And the Americans basically make it plain to the government. They say, if the communists end up properly taking over, we will send in troops from Panama. They mobilize, they have troops on alert in the canal zone in Panama ready to step in. And Picardo, the weedy historian who's still president. Oh, he's still there, is he?
共产党人将坚守在首都。问题是：当菲格雷斯的小部队逼近时，他们会坚守吗？还是他们会接受失败？正是在这一点上，美国变得至关重要，因为当然，这是冷战时期。美国人非常非常反共。美国人基本上向政府表明了他们的态度。他们说，如果共产党最终彻底接管，我们将从巴拿马派遣军队。他们动员起来，在巴拿马运河区处于高度戒备状态，随时准备介入。而皮卡多，那个仍然是总统的软弱历史学家。哦，他还坐在那里，是吗？
He's still hanging around. He's a bit of a figurehead. He sends a message to Calderon and to the communists. And he says, listen, it will be an absolute catastrophe if we have street fighting in the capital. Because as a historian, he would know that, wouldn't he? That would be a lesson of history that he would draw. And if he hadn't been a historian, yes, he could have said street fighting would be brilliant. So this is a victory in some ways for history. It's a vindication of history. I think it is.
他还赖着不走。他有点像个傀儡。他给卡尔德隆和共产党人发了一条消息。他说，听着，如果我们首都发生街头巷战，将是一场绝对的灾难。作为一个历史学家，他会知道这一点的，不是吗？那是他会从中吸取的历史教训。如果他不是历史学家，是的，他可能会说街头巷战太棒了。所以这在某种程度上是历史的胜利。这是对历史的平反。我认为是的。
So, and he says basically the united states will step in and this will be a disaster we can't have this so the picardo the communists and calderon they all agree they will give up okay calderon goes off to um nicaragua with picardo the historian so the doctor and the historian are gone the communists just sort of melt away after a bit of fighting on the 24th of april so you know what is it what are we less than two months after the the whole business began uh figueres's forces enter san jose and they take over the government so not big death toll about um about 2 000 people the war lasted 44 days well wait for it wait for it so just to tell you what happened to all the characters picardo the historian he stayed in
所以，他基本上说美国将介入，这将是一场灾难，我们不能允许这种事发生，所以皮卡多、共产党人和卡尔德隆都同意放弃。好吧，卡尔德隆和历史学家皮卡多一起去了尼加拉瓜。所以医生和历史学家都走了。共产党人在经过一番战斗后，于 4月 24日左右自行瓦解。所以，你知道，整个事情开始不到两个月，菲格雷斯的军队进入圣何塞并接管了政府。死亡人数不多，大约 2000人，战争持续了 44天。好吧，等等，等等！所以只是为了告诉你所有这些角色的结局：历史学家皮卡多永远留在了尼加拉瓜，再也没有回来，那是他的结局；医生卡尔德隆去了墨西哥流亡，在那里他奇怪地又回去当了医生，然后他回到了哥斯达黎加，竞选总统但没有成功，最后担任了哥斯达黎加驻墨西哥大使，这是一个相当温和的结局。现在，这就是关于哥斯达黎加命运的线索。因为事实上，我们之前谈到的所有这些都是标准的拉丁美洲桥段，不是吗？各种阴谋诡计，名字叫堂佩佩的人，所有这些标准的拉丁美洲桥段，不是吗？各种阴谋诡计，名字叫堂佩佩的人，等等。但真正发生的是接下来发生的事，这才是区别所在。现在发生的是，菲格雷斯掌权 18个月，他基本上说我将掌权，然后我会交权，我没有当独裁者的野心。
nicaragua forever he never came back that was the end of him calderon the doctor he goes he's in exile in mexico where he bizarrely he just goes back to being a doctor again then he comes back to costa rica he runs for president unsuccessfully and ends up as an ambassador to Mexico from Costa Rica, which is quite a benevolent outcome. Now, that is a clue about what happens to Costa Rica. Because actually, everything that we've talked about till now is sort of standard Latin American stuff, isn't it? Clues and people called Don Pepe and all that sort of standard latin american stuff isn't it clues and people called don pepe and yeah all that sort of thing but what actually happened is what happens that is the difference what happens now because figueres he takes power for 18 months and he's basically says i will take power
尼加拉瓜，他再也没有回来，他就这样结束了。卡尔德龙医生去了墨西哥流亡，在那里他奇怪地重操旧业，又当回了医生。后来他回到哥斯达黎加，竞选总统但未成功，最终担任哥斯达黎加驻墨西哥大使，这算是一个相当温和结局。这其实暗示了哥斯达黎加后来的命运。因为事实上，我们刚才谈到的一切都算是拉美常态，不是吗？各种线索、被称为唐·佩佩（Don Pepe）的人以及所有这些拉美常态，但是真正发生的事情，也就是接下来发生的事情，才是关键所在。菲格雷斯掌权了18个月，他基本上说我会掌权
and then i'll give it up i have no ambition to be a dictator. This is the guy we talked about as the Catalan who read Cervantes and was a sort of kindly rope employer. And in his 18 months, he gives women the vote. He abolishes the sort of reading requirements, the literacy requirement for voting. He confirms the existing welfare legislation. He nationalizes the banks. He writes a new constitution, expands public education. He gives citizenship to the children of black immigrants, which had previously been denied them. But he does one thing above all, for which Costa Rica really is famous. He abolishes the army. Oh, yes, of course.
这就是我们之前谈到的那个读过塞万提斯的加泰罗尼亚人，一个善良的绳索雇主。在他执政的 18个月里，他赋予了女性投票权。他废除了投票的识字要求。他确认了现有的福利立法。他将银行国有化。他起草了一篇新宪法，扩大了公共教育。他赋予了黑人移民子女公民身份，这在以前是被剥夺的。但他做了一件最重要的事情，哥斯达黎加也因此真正闻名于世：他废除了军队。哦，是的，当然。
And Costa Rica is still the only country of its size with no army um and why does figueres do it well he basically he knows that the army is sort of untrustworthy i suppose he's frightened maybe of a coup so and he knows that the army was working for his adversaries but also there's a kind of idealism there. He basically says, if you don't have an army, then you won't have more coups and you won't have civil wars. And he's also, crucially, I talked about his reading in the Boston Public Library in H.G. Wells. H.G. Wells, in his book, The Outline of History, predicted a future with no armies. And he had said, a world with no army, this sort of pacifist world would be a better one. Figueres genuinely believes it.
而且哥斯达黎加至今仍然是其体量范围内唯一没有军队的国家。嗯，为什么菲格雷斯要这么做呢？嗯，他基本上知道军队某种程度上是不可信的，我想他可能害怕发生政变。所以他知道军队曾为他的对手效力，但其中也有一种理想主义。他基本上说，如果你没有军队，你就不会再发生政变，也不会有内战。而且至关重要的是，我之前提到过他在波士顿公共图书馆对 H.G.威尔斯的阅读。H.G.威尔斯在他的《世界史纲》（The Outline of History）一书中，预言了一个没有军队的未来。他说，一个没有军队的世界，这种太平洋式的世界将会是一个更好的世界。菲格雷斯真心相信这一点。
And that is a kind of much nobler way to not have an army than Qatar that we talked about in our first episode, which also doesn't have an army. So there's a parallel. And then does he give up power? So he gives up power. He literally walks away. So he's like S's like he's like sulla
比起我们在第一集里谈到的同样没有军队的卡塔尔，这是一种高尚得多、不需要有军队的方式。所以这其中有相似之处。然后他交权了吗？所以他交权了。他真的就这么一走了之了。所以他就像……他就像苏拉（Sulla）。
the a bit like the roman dictator but but obviously less bloodthirsty sulla kept coming back didn't he no sulla laid down his dictatorial powers and then went off and died of intestinal worms but i mean he killed a lot of people but it sounds like don pepe don pepe didn't kill anybody no he's a much more benevolent figure He walked away and then just became a democratic politician. So he actually had two more terms as president. What an admirable man. In the 1950s and 1970s. He had such an interesting sort of political identity.
有点像罗马独裁者，但显然没有那么嗜血。苏拉不是又回来了吗？不，苏拉卸下了他的独裁权力，然后离开并死于肠道寄生虫。但我的意思是，他杀了很多很多人。但听起来堂佩佩……堂佩佩没有杀任何人。不，他是一个温和得多的政治人物。他一走了之，然后成了一名民主政客。所以他实际上还在 20世纪 50年代和 70年代又担任了两任总统。多么令人钦佩的人啊。他有着非常有趣的政治身份。
He was always close to the United States because, of course, he studied in Boston. Yeah, reading all that stuff in the library. He was very careful. So he would sort of criticize them in public and in private, saying he used to say, your hands are not clean to fight communism if you don't also fight dictatorships. And he's not wrong. He took money from the CIA and the KGB, interestingly. So he's not only a benevolent man, but a canny man, yeah. He's a canny man. When, in the 70s, when he's quite an old man and president again, some Nicaraguans hijacked a plane in San Jose in 1971. And when Figueres heard about it, he went straight, he was 5'3",
他一直与美国保持密切关系，因为当然，他在波士顿学习过。是的，在图书馆里读了那么多书。他非常小心。所以他会在公开场合和私下批评他们，他过去常常说：“如果你们不同时反对独裁政权，你们的手就不干净，无法与共产主义作斗争。”他说得没错。有趣的是，他还拿过中情局（CIA）和克格勃（KGB）的钱。所以他不仅是一个仁慈的人，而且是一个精明的人，是的。他是个精明的人。在 70年代，当他年事已高并再次担任总统时，一些尼加拉瓜人于 1971年在圣何塞劫持了一架飞机。当菲格雷斯听说这件事时，他直接……他身高只有 5英尺 3英寸（约 160厘米），所以非常矮。他亲自带着一把冲锋枪径直前往机场，用枪指着机舱里的劫机者，直到他们投降。所以他是个勇敢的人。所以他既仁慈、精明，又是一个敢作敢当的英雄。他确实是。他听起来是 20世纪后期最卓越的政治领袖之一。据说他去参加一个中美洲峰会时，由于这种种行为，他在其他中美洲强人那里受到的评价很低。他去了，但在 1973年的一次中美洲峰会上，据说他说……根据他自己的描述，他毁了那里的气氛。他通过对他们说这样的话，把一切都搞砸了：“难道不奇怪吗……”
so very short. He went straight to the airport himself with a submachine gun and pointed it at the hijackers in the cabin until they surrendered. So he's a brave man. So he's benevolent, he's canny, and he's a have-a-go hero. He is. He sounds one of the most remarkable political leaders of the late 20th century. Apparently he went to a Central American summit where he was held in low regard by other Central American strongmen for all this behavior. And he went, but in a Central American summit in 1973, he said, apparently said, ruined the atmosphere, apparently by his own description. He spoiled it for them all by saying to them, isn't it odd that
非常短暂。他自己拿着冲锋枪直接去了机场，用枪指着客舱里的劫机者，直到他们投降。所以他是个勇敢的人。他很仁慈，精明，而且是个见义勇为的英雄。确实如此。他听起来是20世纪后期最卓越的政治领袖之一。据说他去参加一个中美洲峰会时，由于这些行为，他在其他中美洲独裁者中并不受欢迎。他去了，但在1973年的一次中美洲峰会上，据他自己的描述，他破坏了气氛。他用这样一句话扫了大家的兴：难道不奇怪吗？
all you bastards are generals and I'm the only civilian, but I'm the only one who's ever fought and won a war. He sounds great. I love him. I love and i took to say it again the thing i'm loving about this series is learning about all kinds of things i knew nothing about i think he is dominic i think he's my favorite 20th century hiking south american leader well central american leader i think he is proof that political choices genuinely make a difference to countries' destinies. Because if you look at Costa Rica right now, it has the lowest crime, the highest literacy, the best health care, the greatest stability, and indeed the best football team in Central America. And the best frogs. And the best frogs.
你们这群混蛋都是将军，而我唯一的平民，但我却是唯一一个打过并赢得战争的人。他听起来太棒了。我爱他。我再次要说的是，我喜欢这个系列的地方在于能了解各种我一无所知的事情。我认为他是多米尼克，我觉得他是 我最喜欢的20世纪南美徒步旅行领袖，哦不，中美洲领袖。我认为他是政治选择确实能改变国家命运的证明。因为如果你看看现在的哥斯达黎加，它拥有中美洲最低的犯罪率、最高的识字率、最好的医疗保健、最大的稳定性，以及确实最好的足球队。还有最好的青蛙。还有最好的青蛙。
And it still, of course, has no… Despite the efforts of the evil Dr. Valverde. Dr. Valverde. I like to think that you'll get angry letters from his descendants, Tom, about your shamefulness. But I'll tell you, do you know what they did with the army? Do you know what happened? Well, of course you don't, because you've said yourself
而且它当然仍然没有……尽管邪恶的瓦尔韦德博士做出了种种努力。瓦尔韦德博士。汤姆，我猜你可能会收到他的后代发来的愤怒信，指责你的无耻。但我告诉你，你知道他们对军队做了什么吗？你知道发生了什么吗？好吧，你当然不知道，因为你自己说过
you don't know about Costa Rican history. So they had a public ceremony when they abolished it in 1949. And they had a public ceremony. And the commander-in- chief in public took the key to the army headquarters, and he handed it to the minister of education, who announced that it would henceforth become a museum. Wow. And it still is. Swords beaten into school textbooks. Exactly. So there is Costa Rican history. Amazing, Dominic. Wonderful. I honestly thought this was going to be probably the most boring episode, but I completely apologize. That was a brilliant episode. So thank you very much. I think the highlight of that was
你对哥斯达黎加历史一无所知。所以在1949年废除军队时，他们举行了一场公开仪式。他们举行了一场公开仪式。总司令在公开场合把军队总部的钥匙交给了教育部长，教育部长宣布这里从此将成为一座博物馆。哇。现在依然是。铸剑为犁变成了教科书。没错。这就是哥斯达黎加的历史。太棒了，多米尼克。太精彩了。我老实以为这可能会是最无聊的一集，但我完全道歉。这是一集精彩绝伦的节目。非常感谢你们。我想其中的亮点是
your discussion of poor old Dr. Valfoy. Well, I hope that everyone else listening enjoyed that as much as I did. Thank you all for listening. We'll be back with more world cup related historical shenanigans tomorrow bye-bye adios thanks for listening to the rest is history episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
你对可怜的老瓦尔福伊博士的讨论。好吧，我希望其他听众也和我一样喜欢这一集。谢谢大家的收听。明天我们将带着更多与世界杯相关的历史趣事回归，再见，adios，感谢收听《The Rest Is History》，如需收听更多节目、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、八卦和问答的地方，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集以及优先购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集暂时还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。